we discuss we discuss the critical role
of exercise and treating chronic pain
and then we wrote up a plan at the end
of the visit shouldn't run over time by
too much she said something that I'd
read about but never actually heard a
patient legitimately say just talking
about all this she said has made me feel
better I wanted to jump up and sing an
aria which luckily for all parties
involved I refrain from but I was in the
process of realizing something else just
talking it all out made me feel better
you can watch this and other programs
online at book tv.org and now book TV is
live from the 8th annual Gaithersburg
Book Festival today you'll hear from
several authors including Ronald Reagan
biographer Craig Shirley Fox News
contributor Juan Williams former White
House aide Sidney Blumenthal foreign
policy magazine's executive editor
Sharon Weinberger and many more first up
though here's maria Olson she's the
author of not the cleaver family about
the modern family structure this is book
TVs live coverage of the gatorsburg Book
Festival
good morning how's everybody doing I'm
Danny when born and I am a planning
Commissioner in the city of Gaithersburg
as well as a member of the Book Festival
committee this is our annual our eighth
annual Book Festival and we are so happy
to have everyone here Gaithersburg is a
wonderful city that proudly supports the
arts and humanities we are pleased to
bring you this fabulous event thanks in
part to the general support of our
sponsors and volunteers when you see
them please say thank you a few
announcements for the consideration of
everyone here we'd like for you to
silence all devices and if you're
tweeting today use hash tag pound sign
GBF we also have a survey that we'd like
your feedback so we can keep making this
a better better festival every year and
MS Olson will be signing books
immediately following her presentations
a quick word about buying books I just
bought about five books myself so I'm
not just asked I'm not preaching to the
choir I'm part of the choir but it
really helps the Book Festival so when
you have an opportunity please go over
to the politics and prose tent and
purchase some books as you know the city
of Gaithersburg is has been cited as one
of the most ever cities in America for
its cultural and racial mix this is a
new contemporary life for citizens of
Gaithersburg and we're hoping that it
spreads throughout the nation the Maria
Leonard Olsen has crafted a book that
addresses real contemporary life in
America miss Olsen herself has a
multiracial family and lives that of
which she writes she said that she is
often mistaken for the nanny for her
biracial children I'm sure she'll talk
to us about that
what is family in America despite the
current climate the reality is that
America is changing and has changed
within the next twenty to thirty years
as Miss Olsen points out in her book
less than half the population of America
will be white miss Olsen includes
herself excuse me has has given hundreds
of interviews and includes those in the
book that she's going to talk about but
families that she's talked to talked to
throughout America a few weeks ago our
own mayor Jud Ashman was on the W kamau
Bell show on United shades of America to
discuss what it's like to be the mayor
of one of the most diverse cities in the
country
I urge you to go look at that on CNN and
see what his response is Gaithersburg
has experienced a shift in the in in
what's coming in America and now we're
gonna talk about that prior paradigm
shift the name of the book is not the
cleaver family and I'd like to warmly
welcome miss Maria Leonard Olsen to the
Dyess
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for that I am so
excited to be here I grew up in
Montgomery County as the and I was the
only dark-skinned person in my entire
white porochial Kensington classroom in
the 1960s through 70s
my parents were forbidden by law to
marry in the state of Maryland in 1961
when I tell my children that or even
strangers that they're incredulous that
it was illegal in 16 states including
Maryland in Virginia for people of other
races to marry period that is crazy and
likewise when my children tell their
children that dad and dad weren't able
to marry until 2015
they won't believe it there are so many
changes going on in our society right
now the rapidity with which the family
paradigm is changing is really quite
remarkable that only in my childhood
people couldn't get married who are of
two different races and now
it is so common no one would blink an
eye although I still don't want my
children going to school in the South
because I have experienced racism in the
south so there are pockets of racism
which we all know we all know but the
tide is shifting and my book is a it's
an examination of how the tide is
changing and what we can do to support
people whose families aren't like the
cleaver family how many people here
remember the cleaver family show
well I dreamed of becoming of being the
cleaver family I wanted my mom to vacuum
in high heels and pearls I wanted my
father to be seated in his armchair
dispensing wisdom to my brother and me I
just thought that was the ultimate and
that's not what I had I kids can be
cruel we all know that I suspect that
every person here can remember something
mean someone said to them when they were
a child because that's just the cruel
nature of childhood we're all trying to
find our places and as a result some
people can get nasty to others my my
cross to bear at that time was I was
raised Catholic went to a Catholic
school my entire life and there were my
parents got divorced so they were at
that time excommunicated from the
Catholic Church there were children who
were not allowed to come to my house
because my parents were divorced and
excommunicated my father got custody of
my brother and me I believe partially
because of racism there was talk of
having my mom deported to the
Philippines and I still don't understand
what happened but I'm glad that that's
not the case today
that that is not the basis from which
child custody
Awards are made in any event I as was
mentioned have two children this is the
first book I ever wrote called mommy
why's your skin so brown
and the reason I wrote it is because so
many people assumed because I am
dark-skinned and my children are
light-skinned that I was surely their
nanny
I couldn't possibly be their mother so I
started talking to people that I knew
who had children who didn't look like
them whether they were adopted or of
another race or mixed race and found
that I was not alone the history of
racism in our country has always been
more vicious against african-americans
than Asians and Latinas however there
was no other dark-skinned person in my
all-white neighborhood when I was
raising my children who was not a
domestic worker it got to a point where
even a Filipino nanny came up to me
while I was pushing my son in the
stroller and said oh he's so cute
are you live in and I'm like yes I don't
even know if I can say this on TV and
I'm sleeping with the father and after
that moment the various nannies in the
town of Chevy Chase
they still point to me and say there she
is that harlot then I go proudly with my
children my son actually has blue eyes
it is such a strange anomaly because you
have to go back to generations in my
family to find the gene for blue eyes
but it happened and he was blond for his
first year so a lot of things happened
along the lines of people mistaking me
for the nanny like the dentist or the
dentist's would say well would the mom
like and the Gymboree teacher would say
so mom's and nanny let's gather and to
have circle time and I'd look around at
all the blonde moms and say hmm this is
not going to end well and so she asked
if I had ever had a birthing experience
and I said yes this is my second one
so it was kind of a cathartic experience
to write this I also wrote an article
for the post that they bought they
didn't print but it got printed in the
Montgomery County Journal called being a
parent isn't always a parent
appa are EMT and that article was widely
distributed to area preschools to raise
consciousness about how parents don't
always look like their children and some
people have two female parents nowadays
or two male parents my father later in
life married a younger woman and people
mistook him for the grandfather of my
half-brother I have a complicated family
and I was dismayed because my
half-brother thought my father is so old
he's surely going to die soon so when
people let their curiosity overwhelm
their manners and save insensitive
things especially in the presence of
children they're not always aware of the
effects I wished that I looked like
everyone else when I was growing up my
half-brother wished that his dad was
younger and that he wouldn't die and
that people wouldn't assume he was the
grandfather things are changing now
school forms for instance now frequently
say parent 1 and parent 2 instead of
mother and father that is a huge sea
change I believe that we're going to see
more and more as time goes on but it
even in the last decade has been a time
of momentous change for the families in
our country I am I then started
interviewing people after the success of
this book and the article I started
interviewing people in five different
groups people who adopted their children
people who chose not to have children
child free by choice is the
fastest-growing demographic of all those
I studied
parents of Singleton's when I was a
child having no brothers or sisters was
cause for pity we were sorry felt sorry
for those children but now people choose
to have one child because of family
resources time careers there are a lot
of reasons people choose that
let me just forgive a little bit about
each chapter that I studied first I'd
like to say as was alluded to in 2013
the Census Bureau reported that within a
year white children under the age of
five would be a minority and that by
2043 less than 50% of the US population
will be white
that's an incredible statistic that our
country is going to go to a state where
lights are not the majority I never
thought I would live to see that but the
Beijing of America is is underway I am
happy for my children that they no
longer have to check white or Asian
Pacific Islander because if they have to
choose then they're saying no to one
side of their families I always had to
choose Asian Pacific Islander because if
I chose white which my father is white
no one would accept that they teachers
would even say well I think you did this
wrong so they don't have to face that
anymore mixed-race is a box on almost
every sort of demographic keeping paper
while laws and social services are slow
to keep up with some changes the point
of my book is that there is no normal
that we are a Beijing country we are a
country where a lot of different
families are accepted now and the
paradigms have shifted
I spoke to hundreds of people across the
country about their experiences which
did differ as we saw from the last
election the coasts are their own
political country and middle America is
somewhat different slower to accept
changes but changes done the less are
underway the first chapter is about
child free by choice our culture seems
to equate womanhood with motherhood
people who choose not to have children
are often shamed by their colleagues or
friends for not having children the
minute I got married my grandmother
started asking me when I was going to
have children because procreation in
couplehood is just assumed well I would
like to debunk that assumption
many people are fulfilled without being
parents it's not for everyone and
contrary to the notion that it may be
selfish to not have children
I think it's selfish to have children if
you're not ready for it and you don't
have the time or resources to give that
child what he or she deserves the women
and men that I interviewed cited
financial issues career concerns lack of
maternal and paternal instinct negative
childhood experiences the environmental
impact of overpopulation and the desire
not to bring children into a violent
world as their major reasons for not
procreating and every one of the
interviewees was aware of our kids
centric culture and battled negative
comments about their decision not to
have children I'm trying to do my part
to dispel those assumptions and to help
people
be honored with whatever choice they
make mixed-race families according to
the 2008 census 15% of new marriages are
interracial and yet are you all familiar
with the Cheerios ad that was so
controversial people started boycotting
Cheerios one of our most popular cereals
because they featured on TV a commercial
featuring a white mother and a black
father and a mixed-race kid it was a
huge uproar which just floored me there
is a very interesting website called we
are the 15% where mixed-race families
sent in pictures of their families to to
show that we are normal - now I see
mixed-race ads at least in print media
often especially in New York the
billboards that sort of de rigueur as I
said almost every multiracial person
I've met has been faced with the
question what are you sometimes when I'm
in a bad mood I say human but why should
I have to face that I do face that
almost every day but if I say I'm
American
they look at me with puzzlement and
often will not accept that for an answer
if I say Filipino then they'll let me
pass but it's very crazy in foreign
countries as well I've had that
experience but I don't want to be
compelled to choose I want to honor my
father's Irish American heritage as well
as my mother's Filipino heritage because
of the assumptions made in our country
I've been mistaken also as a waitress at
country clubs my friend who is a
prosecutor was mistaken for a criminal
trying to steal his white girls from a
playground in Montgomery County because
they are so fair-skinned and he is so
dark-skinned twice someone called the
police saying this man is trying to
steal these kids
from the from the playground so we have
we have some way to go and these
assumptions are ingrained in childhood
but together the people like you are
interested in this topic can make
changes through your conversations
through your actions through your not
making assumptions through your calling
people out when they do make assumptions
and I am getting better and better at
that every day my children are both in
college and there are pretty liberal
universities and the first day of class
the professor asks what's your name and
by what pronoun would you like to be
called the gender binary is slowly
eroding I walk on eggshells around my
kids because if I assumed I had a
pronoun they get very upset single
parents many of the women I interviewed
focused on their careers during their
prime childbearing years and then they
found that they were older and didn't
get have time to get married
well now science enables us to have
children without without a parent you
can have a sperm donor I have two
colleagues from law firms I worked at
I'm a lawyer as well or from law school
who chose to have children by themselves
using a sperm donor and that's a valid
choice nowadays there's a huge network
online of women who have chosen this
parents of Singleton's the one-child
household it's the fastest growing
family unit
singleton children often fare better
than kids in large families or even with
two children because the parents treat
them as adults much earlier and their
vocabularies are expanded as a result
they have higher IQs by some measures
families who adopt when I was growing up
you were adopted was like a disc at one
of your friends and it was a fearful
thing it was a nun
anything to think that I might have been
adopted but why why is being adopted why
was it seen in my neighborhood as being
something negative it's a beautiful
thing
and when people address my friends who
have adopted children by with questions
such as Oh where'd you get her as if she
were a commodity that is a harmful thing
so what can we do education is the
primary way I believe to eradicate
prejudice and to raise consciousness on
these efforts
I attend the mixed remixed festival
every year in Los Angeles which is the
largest gathering of mixed-race people
in the United States and it's the first
time I ever felt truly understood I
exist somewhere in the middle like I've
never felt truly American and I
certainly have never felt Filipino
because my mother wanted me to be so
American and didn't teach me the
language well that was a loss of a great
gift so I am on a personal quest if any
of you speak another language or have
another culture in your heritage
please share that with your children or
they'll grow up like me resentful that
their parents did not allow that into
the house so discuss and celebrate these
differences from a young age I also host
an LGBT radio show on WPF wfm called
inside out it's the only LGBT radio show
on the FM dial in Washington DC that's
pretty stunning to me because we have a
huge LGBT community in Washington so I
do my part to eradicate prejudices and
assumptions via the radio waves as well
so I do want to leave a couple minutes
for questions and answers someone has a
mic yes to to come by if you have a
comment about your story I have a
Facebook page where I'm encouraging
people to share their stories about
their
traditional families as well and I would
love to hear from you I would like to
expand this project in the future to
have a place for people with
non-traditional families to meet and
confer and share strategies for dealing
with some of the indignities that we do
with so who would like to ask a question
or make a comment yes
Oh
I don't know how to make this a question
because I know Ari I already know a
little about you but I isn't it
important to think less in terms how do
we fight the bad evil races and more how
do we can't open people's minds and
hearts yes in other words we every time
we meet somebody with them who has a
lifetime prejudice because their parents
and everybody taught him and that's all
they know and they don't even know
they're prejudiced frankly isn't it's so
much more important in my mind to
introduce them cordially yes that's true
to somebody that doesn't fit their
stereo - I believe that is is the truth
and perhaps I spoke too vehemently about
certain topics but what I do want to say
is for instance everyone here knows
someone who is gay but before you knew
someone who was gay wasn't there a
little bit of misunderstanding possibly
fear because people are afraid of what's
not familiar to them
so there are some LGBT groups who go
door to door because they want to show
that they're normal they're like anyone
else they're kind they're concerned
about the environment so interactions
yes interactions with kindness helps to
increase understanding you're absolutely
right now thank you for that comment
would anyone else like to make a comment
or a question
thank you so much for your story I'm
really you know intrigued by it but I
I'd like for you to talk a little bit
about your your children how did it
affect them and and when were they aware
that there was a difference right right
children are very good observers but
poor interpreters of what is happening
so at a certain point when my daughter
was about five she we said mommy why is
your skin so brown like why do people
keep asking if you're our babysitter so
I believe it had a bit of a negative a
negative effect on her she didn't like
that we didn't look the same because
people have this tribal desire to fit in
to be part of and it made her
uncomfortable my son
less so less so but my daughter's pretty
sensitive and she it took her some time
to come to terms with the fact that our
skin colors are different now she I'm
proud to say is a huge advocate and
became very involved in her college
group called mixed which is for anyone
of mixed-race are interested in other
cultures there was nothing like that for
me when I was in college I would have
loved that
my best friend from high school
texted me on the way in here and she
said your mixed-race I didn't know that
because I tried really hard to be the
cheerleader the American I just wanted
to be like everyone else
now I revel in my uniqueness now I'm
proud that on bicultural I'm going to
the Philippines bringing my kids there
for the first time this summer and I'm
so excited
and my daughter wants to stay there and
learn Tagalog and I'm hoping that she
does people speak to me in Spanish
almost every day and luckily I learned
it in high school in college and I enjoy
practicing it but I I just kind of want
to say hey I'm actually a Filipino every
time to kind of not
to bring some attention to the fact that
one shouldn't make these kinds of
assumptions and there are fewer probably
Filipinos that people come into contact
with here so I understand why
assumptions are sometimes made but I'm
more apt to talk about it now than I was
so I was thinking that since I have how
many minutes left two minutes three
minutes left I'll tell you about my next
project which I am writing a book called
50 after 50 and it is 50 new things I
tried after turning 50 and what I
learned from them and it's kind of the
transformation of going from someone who
wanted to fit in
to someone who is so happy to be
different and to show the world my
uniqueness when I turned 50 I actually
got my motorcycle license much to the
horror of my children but it was really
quite freeing I had no experience with
motorcycles I'm pretty small so it's
hard to find a motorcycle that I can
hold up but it it was a testament to
myself that I no longer care what other
people think of me it is freeing in that
way to grow to age that we care less and
less about what other people think and
more about how we feel about ourselves
at least this person does and I'm really
excited so keep a look out for 50 after
50 and I will be signing books at area a
and also in the politics in prose 10th I
work for politics and prose as well as
an off-site bookseller because I love
authors talks and I love books and I
know I'm preaching to the choir but
politics and prose is the most amazing
bookstore in the country and I hope that
you'll come by visit us there thank you
so much
[Applause]
Thank You Maria so we want everyone to
enjoy the rest of the festival and make
sure you visit politics and prose have a
good afternoon
okay
[Applause]
and that was Maria Olson in just a few
minutes we have more live coverage of
the eighth annual Gaithersburg Book
Festival next up melvin goodman will
discuss his book whistleblower
at the CIA
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country from May 31st to June 2nd look
for us at the publishing industry's
annual trade show Book Expo America in
New York City
where we'll sit down with authors and
publishers to discuss their forthcoming
books later in June we'll be live from
the 33rd annual printers roll it fest in
Chicago followed by the annual Roosevelt
reading festival hosted by the FDR
Presidential Library and Museum in Hyde
Park New York on June 17th for more
information about the book fairs and
festivals book TV will be covering and
to watch previous festival coverage
click the book fairs tab on our website
book TV org
being a Zapruder meant a lot of things
and not being a Washingtonian it meant
being from a liberal family it meant
being Jewish it meant being the children
of my you know incredibly interesting
engaging parents lots of social
gathering it meant we all have these
identities that are formed by what we
grow up with and then there are the
identities that you don't realize that
you've inherited and that is what the
story of the supporter film is for me I
didn't I didn't understand for most of
my life that when I met someone they
might come to the meeting of me with a
whole set of assumptions or ideas or
understanding about this past that I
didn't know about it may be experts
watched a thousand times and never
watched it I mean absolutely never
watched it until until deciding to work
on this book so again in some ways it
was a very strange gift for the work
because coming to it with no background
in a way coming to it completely clean
meant that I could mine my own memories
in a way and then layer in this
information that I was learning it
wasn't like I one of the things that I
often said about this work as I was
doing it was I didn't come to this book
with a story to tell I didn't come to it
saying I have this whole story that I
need to impart to you I came to the work
with questions and with suspicions and
with ideas and and the book is the
inquiry the book is the is those is the
attempt to sort of put together these
pieces and one of the things I think
that is the most most important thing
about the work is that I realized when I
began reading about the film sort of
with in with it in mind that I might
want to write something about it
after my father died I realized that no
one really talked about it as a home
movie and it's interesting that you
brought that up people talk about it as
evidence people talk about it as an
artifact that was ended up being worth a
lot of money people talk about it as a
cultural touchstone
people look at it as you know a lens
through which so to speak a lens through
which you can look at media ethics and
changing Maurice but for our family and
for my grandfather most of all the whole
movie quality of it the fact that he had
been making home movies for 35 years at
that point and that or 30 years and that
he it was his camera and his point of
view and it was his responsibility
shaped everything that followed and I
think not knowing that and not sort of
putting the whole movie back at the
center of the story that it just meant
that there were so many distortions in
the way that the story was told and the
other public records you can watch this
and other programs online at book tv.org
and we're back now with more live
coverage of the 8th annual Gaithersburg
Book Festival melvin goodman will talk
about his time with the CIA
welcome to the Gaithersburg Book
Festival my name is Audrey Bastian and I
am Washington independent review of
books representative here helping at the
festival Gaithersburg is a city that
proudly supports the arts and humanities
we are pleased to bring you this
fabulous event thanks in part to the
generous support of our sponsors and
volunteers when you say that when you
see them please say thanks a few
announcements please silence your
cellphone's
if you're on social media today we hope
you are please use the hashtag gph or
gb/s and I think I'm seeing GBF 17 so
check that out your feedback is really
valuable to us surveys are available
here at the 10th and on our web site by
submitting a survey you'll be entered
into a drawing for $100 Visa gift card
melvin goodman will be signing books
immediately after this presentation
copies of his book right here are on
sale at the politics and prose exhibit
over there politics approach 10th a
quick word about buying books this is a
free event but it does help the Book
Festival if you buy a book the more
books we sell at our events the more
publishers will want to send their
authors here to speak with us and
purchasing our books purchasing books
from our partner politics and prose help
support one of the world's great it's
independent bookstores and it benefits
our local economy and supports local
jobs so if you're enjoying this program
we hope that you'll buy a book today or
several books hmm melvin goodman was a
soviet analyst at the CIA in the
Department of State for 24 years and a
professor of international relations at
the Naval National War College for 18
years he served in the US Army in Athens
Greece for three years and was
intelligent adviser to the salt
delegation from 1971 to 1972 currently
Goodman is the director of the National
Security Project at the Center for
international policy in Washington DC
and an adjunct professor of government
at John Hopkins University his latest
book is whistleblower at the CIA an
insider's account
two of the politics of intelligence he
also authored co-authored and edited
seven books including national security
or national insecurity the cost of
American militarism published by city
lights
Gorbachev's retreat the third world the
Wars of Edward Shivaji I know seven
artists thank you good the phantom
defense America's pursuit of the Star
Wars illusion bush-league diplomacy how
the neoconservatives are putting the
world at risk and failure of
intelligence the decline and fall of the
CIA fail fall of the CIA his articles
and op-eds have appeared in numerous
publications including the New York
Times Harper's a foreign policy Foreign
Service Journal the Baltimore Sun and
the Washington Post and he lives in
Bethesda Maryland I have been reading
his book and it's very interesting I was
once recruited for the CIA and I found
this very interesting so thank you very
much thank you very much but it's nice
to be back here again especially when
it's not raining I was here as three
years ago with national insecurity and
this is a wonderful festival and just a
wonderful event I'll start with May the
8th 2017 which is a very important date
for two reasons one reason that's when
the book came out and it was important
to me because I had to submit it to the
CIA for review as part of my contract
with the CIA
it took them 11 months to review this
book now I know they're slow reading but
I think that goes beyond the limit and
raises a real right to speak or freedom
of speech issue that I'll get to maybe
at the end of the talk the other reason
why May the 8th 2017 is very important
to me is because that's the day Sally
Yates testified I found her testimony
riveting and it was riveting on several
levels but the most important level to
me and why I have such incredible
respect for that woman is the highest
duty of any
public servant at any level of
government is to expose misconduct is to
tell the truth when it comes to matters
of legality or morality or simple
transgression or misconduct and one of
the reasons why I wrote the book this
particular book was basically to tell my
story and the story is a simple one in a
sense
I spent 42 years with the government
when you look at my service in the Army
in the Department of Defense in the
Central Intelligence Agency in the
Department of State throughout that
entire period the 42 year period I had
security clearances at the highest level
so I know what security is I know about
the importance of security but I also
learned over a period of time and not
that I you don't enter public service to
become a dissident let alone a
whistleblower but I also learned there's
a credible misuse of intelligence and
just on one level think about the fact
that in our history there have been four
wars that we have fought where
intelligence was used in a dishonest way
to justify the use of force the
mexican-american war the Spanish
American War the Vietnam War of course
is obvious and then one of the worst
examples of all which I dealt with in my
earlier books was the Iraq war which was
a total misuse of intelligence a total
lie in terms of everything the American
public was totally now another reason
why I decided to write the book was the
importance of the whistleblower and I
don't like the term whistleblower
I've never liked it it has a very bad
connotation it has the connotation of a
snitch or a rat think or a stoolie and
that is not what a whistleblower is all
about and I give a certain amount of
credit even though I'm disturbed by what
Ralph Nader did in the year 2000 but it
was Ralph Nader who I think made the
word whistleblower respectable from his
writings in the 1970s and that's
extremely important but when you think
about a whistleblower intern
of some of the great disasters we've had
to deal with in just the last 30 40
years of our own experience think of the
role of the whistleblower in Watergate
now I know all the credit goes to Bob
Woodward and Carl Bernstein and they
deserved the credit
very little credit or fame ever goes to
the whistleblower in this case mark felt
and one of the interesting things about
mark felt was when the White House the
Nixon White House was first dealing with
the problem that there were serious
leaks that had to come from the top and
remember the United States is the ship
of state that leaks from the top not
from the bottom Haldeman knew it was
Mark felt he told Richard Nixon that I
think it's mark felt over at the FBI the
deputy at the FBI and Nixon's first
response was dizzy Jewish and hauled him
and responded no I think he's Catholic
I don't know what either one would have
to do with it but the role of mark felt
in the case of Watergate is extremely
significant when I think of Vietnam I
don't know what the first thought that
comes to your mind is it's the Pentagon
Papers and when I think of the Pentagon
Papers I think of Daniel Ellsberg and
the work that Daniel Ellsberg did in the
1970s and continues to do including
writing a very nice blurb for the book
that I'm very proud of and in June I'm
going to appear with Daniel Ellsberg and
Berkeley at an event to talk about
whistleblowers in this particular book
when you think of the scandals of
torture and abuse think of the need for
the whistleblower when you think of Abu
Ghraib the torture and abuse that took
place at a military prison that involved
a whistleblower I know Edward Snowden is
extremely controversial and it's clear
that Edward Snowden broke laws Edward
Snowden has admitted to the fact that he
has broken certain laws dealing with
certain kinds of intelligence
communications intelligences signals
intelligence but Edward Snowden also
told us about unconstitutional not just
illegal but unconstitutional behavior in
the White House that was aimed at all of
the American people this was an
important contribution to our
standing and here is where
whistleblowers I think play a very
important role we've just read about
Chelsea Manning being released from jail
she received a pardon from President
Obama and I know there's a lot of
confusion and controversy about Chelsea
Manning but the fact of the matter is
she exposed war crimes that were taking
place in Iraq and my point is in trying
to understand what a whistleblower is
and why a whistleblower acts the way he
does and I can only speak for myself but
I think I know why these people acted
the way they did you see something in
public life at some point that you know
is wrong and sometimes it becomes so
overwhelming that you feel that you have
to do something about it and I think
mostly whistleblowers and I know again
in my case are extremely naive about
what it means to throw yourself in front
of them a moving train which is the
American government and in my case it
was throwing myself in front of the
nomination of Robert Gates as a CIA
director in 1991 when I testified before
the Senate Intelligence Committee but I
think this is what motivates a
whistleblower you reach a point where
it's wrong not to say something it's
wrong not to do something and I must say
in all of the whistleblower examples
that I cite in the book and that I've
looked at and tried to understand every
whistleblower as far as I'm concerned
has been vindicated Daniel Ellsberg has
certainly been vindicated Edward Snowden
for a lot of us including myself clearly
has been vindicated
I know it's controversial that he left
the country but I think he left the
country because the terrible treatment
that Thomas Drake received and I don't
know if everyone is familiar with the
Thomas Drake case but he is the National
Security Agency whistleblower who was
then accused of violating the Espionage
Act from 1970 by the Obama
administration and what I find
interesting about that is that issue was
put before the Bush administration and
George W Bush who's vilified in many
quarters decided he would not go after
Thomas Drake
but Barack Obama a harvard-trained
lawyer and someone who taught
constitutional law did allow the
government to go after Thomas Drake in
the worst possible way threatening him
with basically spending the rest of his
life in prison until a judge lectured
the Justice Department lawyers and threw
the case out of court essentially let me
spend a few minutes on my particular
example it's not as dramatic as snow
news or Drake's and certainly not
Ellsberg's and some of the other
whistleblower cases that I've looked at
but in the 1980s when Ronald Reagan came
into office and he appointed an extreme
ideologue to be the CIA director William
Casey this was when I first had to
confront the politicization of
intelligence and what it amounted to was
the fact that Ronald Reagan wanted to
increase defense spending in an
unprecedented way in peacetime we had
never seen these kinds of increases
before in peacetime to do that you had
to justify it you've had to have an
enemy you had to have a threat and what
Casey did in his deputy Robert Gates who
then went on become a CIA director and
then a secretary of defense under both
Bush and Obama was to distort the
intelligence to make the Soviet Union
look 10 feet tall the Soviet Union as a
threat the Soviet Union involved in the
attempt to assassinate the Pope in 1981
the Soviet Union involved in
international terrorism none of this was
true and I stayed throughout the early
80s and basically fought these issues
but in 1986 I decided to leave and go to
the National War College to teach and in
1991 when Bob Gates was nominated by
George HW Bush to be the CIA director
that's when I contacted the Senate
Intelligence Committee and testified
against the gates nomination now what
was interesting about the gates
nomination is that's not the first time
he was nominated he was nominated for
the first time in 1987 by Ronald Reagan
this was after the sudden death of Bill
Casey from a brain tumor
gates went before the Senate
Intelligence Committee and then got a
call at night from David Boren senator
born from Oklahoma the Democratic
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee who had to tell Bob you've got
a problem Bob the committee does not
believe you in terms of your disavows of
knowing anything or being involved in
iran-contra I can't get your name out of
the committee and Bob gates went into
the White House the next day talked to
Frank Carlucci and then talked to the
president and pulled his name out but
four years later he was nominated again
it was a very controversial nomination
because of my accusations of
politicization it led to more votes
against Bob gates than had been
registered against all CIA directors
combined going back to 1947 and Harry
Truman's create creation of the CIA but
he was eventually confirmed and what
this meant is someone who would
politicize intelligence was sent back to
run the agency where the politicization
takes place unless you've been involved
in this in one of the government
agencies you cannot imagine the morale
problems that the ethical problems are
created when someone you know who was
involved with blew the cessation comes
back to run the agency that's why I have
so much sympathy for what is going on
now I'm sure in probably every
department every agency in government
when you have a president who has
selected cabinet directors who have
sworn essentially to if not destroy the
department's they've been sent to
certainly to weaken them in every
fundamental way so that was essentially
my reason for going before the Senate
Intelligence Committee and then being
disappointed by the way it was handled
by the press which I thought did not
rise to the challenge and I'll give you
one anecdote which I think reveals what
is wrong with the press even though
they've certainly gotten their act
together in the last 120 days the the
White House started to leak very
uncomplimentary things about me I should
none of them were true and CIA people
who were called denied all the stories
and I was tipped off by a couple of
journalists one from Time magazine one
from the Washington Post but I decided
day on two can play this game
so I started leaking and I leaked two
then wiser of the Washington Post who's
now with the New York Times and Elaine
Cellino from the New York Times a few
the two papers that have the most clout
certainly in Washington as they do today
and for the first several days of the
testimonial and ciolino played it
straight in the New York Times she
reported what I was telling her she
reported what the White House listen to
tell her there was a certain amount of
false equivalence but she was
representing both sides midway in the
confirmation hearings her reporting
tilted completely to benefit Bob gates
and his nomination and his confirmation
and after the hearings were over and he
was confirmed by called Elaine to have
lunch I had an agenda and halfway
through the lunch
I raised my agenda item which was why
was it so obvious the halfway through
the confirmation hearings you abandoned
what I was telling you which was pretty
good inside information of what was
happening in the Senate Intelligence
Committee and she said well I'll tell
you it was clear at that point that he
was going to be confirmed and he would
become the CIA director and a very
important source for me you would go
back to teaching at the National War
College and I'd probably never call you
again and I thought this told me all I
needed to know about what is wrong with
the mainstream media and when you think
of whistleblowers and I'll pick on the
Washington Post since then it's our
hometown newspaper if you go back to the
op-eds of the Washington Post on all of
the whistleblowers and with Snowden
Thomas Drake Chelsea Manning look up the
critical articles that were written
about them by people like Richard Cohen
Ruth Marcus David Ignatius Walter Pincus
Fred Hiatt the editor of the editorial
page and it was always very meaningful
to me that journalism investigative
journalism which relies on whistled
you know where would investigative
journalism be think of Dinah priests of
The Washington Post who won a Pulitzer
Prize well she won a Pulitzer Prize for
her stories about secret prisons that
the CIA was operating in Europe in
Southeast Asia she got that information
from a whistleblower to this day we
still don't know who that whistleblower
was we know a lot about Donna because
she won a full surprise for her work but
the whistleblower isn't anonymous person
but yet when you read the op-eds I
remember the one that I found the most
offensive was Ruth Marcus who referred
to Chelsea Manning as a cross-dressing
Red Riding Red Riding Hood David
Ignatius was very ugly with his comments
about Edward Snowden David Gregory when
he ran Meet the Press had Glen Greenwald
on his show and was extremely critical
for Glenn Greenwald being a conduit for
the information that Edward Snowden
provided when Senator Dianne Feinstein
wrote an incredibly authoritative report
on CIA torture and abuse she was on wolf
blitzer's Situation Room and accused of
having blood on their hands for
revealing all that information about CIA
torture and abuse so the thing I would
like to leave you with at this point
because I do want to leave some time for
your questions and comments is our
democracy right now is in trouble we're
in a very beleaguered State there was an
article in The New York Times about two
weeks ago about I love this word
guardrails the guardrails of democracy
and how the system is working well two
observations one the system will only
work if people make the system work the
system can't work on its own and two I
would argue the system isn't working the
way I would like it to work look at the
intelligence committees that were
created in the 1970s because of the
crimes during the Vietnam era thirty
years after the CIA was created the
Senate Intelligence Committee is not
doing the aggressive job it should be
doing it's not bipartisan Republican
Senator Richard burr from North Carolina
is
doing the work that an intelligence
chairman needs to do and I don't even
have to say anything about Nunez the
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
and the way he was used as a stooge by
the White House being brought into the
White House grounds and given sets of
documents and told to deliver these to
the President of the United States as if
this was new information to the
President of the United States I think
of the inspectors general of the various
agencies an extremely important post
that was weakened by Barack Obama most
of the eight years that Obama was in
office the CIA went without an Inspector
General when I think of Hillary Clinton
and the email problem and frankly the
email problem and commis handling of the
email problem is probably the decisive
reason why hillary clinton was defeated
even though there are other factors that
need to be addressed but hillary clinton
never allowed a permanent inspector
general to be in the State Department
the four years she was there what if
there had been an inspector general who
very early on could have called
attention to the fact that the idea of
having your own email account and
putting the server in your home is
probably not the best idea in the world
the press which I think has suddenly got
its act together and certainly has been
very aggressive with its reporting in
the last 120 days did not do its job
during the campaign the false
equivalence the free ride that Donald
Trump got from even the Washington Post
in The New York Times was really an
embarrassment and I think most major
editors around the country understand
that now when I look at the court system
the federal courts have not been
aggressive in matters dealing with
national security where they give a lot
of benefit of the doubt to the
government and the state secrets
privilege or making people create their
own legal standing for bringing a case
to federal court so it's important that
citizens understand that these so-called
guardrails have to be fortified and that
there should be a certain amount of
standing of what a whistleblower is and
what a whistleblower does and going back
to warnings that we've gotten from
people such as James Madison and
Alexander Hamilton about the importance
of a free press the importance of not
trading off your Liberty for security
and the importance of a public servant
who exposes misconduct I think these are
things we have to keep in mind so we
have less than 10 minutes
[Applause]
the use of whistleblowers is unique to
this country because without our free
press wouldn't we be just no different
than the Soviet Union China or any other
dictatorship well I certainly don't
think it's unique to us and frankly
there are Soviet citizens and Russian
citizens who have taken far more risk
with their lives you know during the
worst of the hearings I tended to look
under the hood of my car before I
started my engine but I'd really didn't
think my life was threatened but in
places such as Russia and China
whistleblowers take tremendous risk in
Britain you had important whistleblowers
dealing with Tony Blair's dishonesty in
joining up with George Bush and the Iraq
war what is unique about the United
States I think and and I worry about
this uniqueness is the court system and
the investigative journalism when it
works people like Seymour Hersh Tony
Lewis when he was alive with the New
York Times James rise and with the New
York Times Greg Miller from the post
does a very good job but I notice now
and I don't know when it got there but
the new the masthead and the Washington
Post it was probably after Trump's
affection or inauguration democracy dies
in darkness go back and read Sinclair
Lewis's it can't happen here which was
written in the 1930s it's happening here
yeah
I think I heard you say earlier that the
primary responsibility of a civil
servant is to expose wrongdoing is that
correct I did is that Alexander Hamilton
by the way planted that seed at mine
okay well that probably answered my
question my question was should that be
the norm or is that an outcome of
current times in other words shouldn't
the primary responsibilities be to do
good as opposed to looking for
wrongdoing oh well I take doing good for
granted
okay I mean why would you do any tasks
by theirs with the government or outside
the government if you weren't having a
beneficial effect but when you get
beyond what are the standard obligations
of a public servant or anyone else
I think truthfulness and confronting
wrongdoing is important and remember it
was Alexander Hamilton and I always go
back to Hamilton first before I read any
of the other founding fathers because
there's so much wisdom there he talked
about impeachment in terms of the number
one offense that has to be addressed is
compromising the public trust and
certainly we've seen too much of that
whether it was Nixon whether it was
Reagan in iran-contra in the 1980s